bonjour bienvenue dans ses cages dans
une france à moitié libéré mais pas
complètement
bonjour aujourd'hui nous allons vous
parler de la réouverture réouverture des
terrasses des bars bonjour estelle
bonjour olivier bonjour à tous bienvenue
dans ses cages ça y est partout en
france les commerces dits non essentiels
les restaurants et les bars du moins
ceux qui possèdent un espace extérieur
mais aussi les lieux culturels ont
rouvert leurs portes au public le 19 mai
dernier
c'est la deuxième étape de ce
déconfinement qui a débuté le 3 mai avec
la levée des restrictions de circulation
indé confinement qui devrait se
poursuivre jusqu'à la fin juin on va
donc aujourd'hui s'intéresser à ces
commerces qualifié de non essentielle et
au secteur de la restauration
dans quel état d'esprit sont ils quelle
difficulté à les attentes comment
perçoivent thil est l'avenir pour en
parler nous serons en deuxième partie
dans un premier temps en liaison avec
thomas fantini pdg du groupe pergaud et
vice-président du medef haute garonne et
puis nous rejoindront ensuite à thierry
véron président de la fédération des
associations de commerçants et artisans
de paris je vous disais après six mois
de fermeture commerce non essentiels
terrasse ou encore cinéma ont rouvert
leurs portes le 19 mai avec protocoles
sanitaires strictes et un couvre-feu
repoussé désormais à 21h dans le secteur
de l'hôtellerie restauration par exemple
ce sont cent sept mille entreprises qui
étaient fermées administrativement
depuis le 30 octobre 2020 alors
forcément le redémarrage peut parfois
être laborieux explications avec le
tiroir cash d'antoine basse
[Musique]
après des mois d'attentes de confinement
de mesures sanitaires en tout genre on
peut apprécier un petit cocktail en
terrasse après avoir fait du shopping
puis enchaîner sur un 6 mai ou un
théâtre
bon on peut pas encore envisager de
finir la soirée en boîte de nuit mais ça
fait quand même plaisir non et pourtant
tout n'est pas si simple pour les
entreprises qui rouvre le secteur de
l'hôtellerie et de la restauration doit
faire face à un problème de taille le
manque de personnel sur les 650 mille
salariés des cent sept mille
établissements français cent mille
aurait décidé de quitter la profession
selon une étude menée par plusieurs
syndicats
un sixième de la profession quand même
face aux fermetures beaucoup ont
simplement décidé de se reconvertir de
changer de voir pour des métiers avec
moins de contraintes notamment pour ce
qui est des horaires et on ne parle pas
des saisonniers que le gouvernement
avait conseillé d'embauché pour les
placer en chômage partiel et qui seront
sans doute moins nombreux qu'il y a un
an cet été n'était d'ailleurs qui
inquiète aussi beaucoup entre les stocks
faramineux de certains magasins qui vont
avoir du mal à être écoulée la peur de
ne pas voir revenir les touristes en
nombre suffisant le manque de
rentabilité passe au maintien de
certaines mesures sanitaires comme les
jauges dans les restaurants ou les
magasins et bien sûr la fin progressive
des aides massives que l'état a mis en
place sans parler des dettes accumulées
pour tenir bon
il va falloir rembourser les femmes au
pge les prêts garantis par l'état
olivier on l'a vu perspectives plutôt
positives avec les réouvertures mais de
l'autre côté elle les aides vont
progressivement à diminuer c'est un
numéro d'équilibriste auquel vont se
prêter les entreprises ces prochains
mois c'est certain pour bofa pour
certaines entreprises
pas tous mais pour certaines entreprises
ça va ça va être très compliqué parce
qu'aujourd'hui on les a maintenus sous
perfusion pendant toute la durée du où
elles étaient fermées et qu'il va bien
falloir à un moment que les choses
s'arrêtent on va pas continuer avec avec
dédé des aides en permanence jusqu'à
jusqu'à un temps infini donc forcément
ça va s'arrêter quand ça va s'arrêter
le problème avec
avec les gens qui sont perfusé c'est que
vous avez vous avez des gens qui vont
péniblement s'en sortir parce que on ne
sait pas ce qui va se passer derrière
c'est à dire que tout le monde table sur
le fait que une fois libérés les gens
vont se ruer dans les restaurants et que
le restaurant va augmenter son chiffre
d'affaires de façon faramineuse mais
c'est pas c'est pas écrit ça c'est à
dire que vous avez vous avez beaucoup de
deux restaurants pour lesquelles ça va
devenir compliqué on vous on est en
train de vous préparer aux passes
sanitaire qui va peut-être être mise en
place dans les restaurants où l'on vous
demandera si vous êtes vacciné ou si
vous avez un test pcr pour rentrer dans
le récent vous avez des gens que ça va
vite bassiner donc que et évidemment ça
va être compliqué et donc c'est
évidemment beaucoup plus agréable de
voir des restaurants qui rouvre aider et
des bars et rouvre mais le problème
c'est que il ya beaucoup de ces de ces
entreprises et même des commerces comme
vous l'avez dit qu'ils ont des stocks
faramineux
il ya beaucoup de ces entreprises qui
vont couler tout simplement quand on va
retirer la perte et et ça va vous allez
passer d'un de chômeurs
partiel et de chômeurs et départ par
l'état des chômeurs tout court parce que
ces gens là ne retrouvons pas de boulot
donc ça va être compliqué et et l'a vu
la manière dont le gouvernement a géré
la crise
on peut se poser des questions sur la
gestion de l'après crise merci olivier
justement va voir comment s'est déroulée
cette reprise dans la deuxième partie de
cette émission et on va commencer par
parler à du secteur de l'hôtellerie et
de la restauration et pour cela nous
sommes en liaison avec thomas fantini
bonjour monsieur vous êtes pdg du groupe
pergaud et vice-président du medef haute
garonne bienvenue dans ces caches
merci monsieur santini vous gérez donc
vous êtes à la tête d'un groupe de
restaurants vous gérer plusieurs
établissements pour commencer comment
s'est déroulée la réouverture est est ce
que les clients étaient au rendez vous
oui tout à fait on a eu de nombreux
clients avec des jauges limitées
forcément en europe qui très rapidement
les établissements malgré même des des
chutes de pluie les gens sont restés
était plutôt heureux et les équipes
aussi est elle heureuse de redémarrer et
quelles sont concrètement les enjeux
auxquels vous êtes confrontés
aujourd'hui
mais il y a plusieurs enjeux c'est cette
baie déjà le rythme de reprise puisque
on a des joueurs je l'imité 6 par table
le soir un confinement à 21h donc qui
pénalise le service du soir
donc tout ça déjà cdd reprise délicate
on ne peut servir qu'à l'extérieur
donc forcément il ya des problèmes de
météo la possible perte de matière
première est en fait le problème de
recrutement puisque on a effectivement
une désaffection sur le métier où des
gens qui sont allés voir ailleurs
et du coup c'est pénalisant pour
le team inactivité sereine pour volleyer
selon vous quelles sont concrètement les
obstacles à cette reprise
ce spectacle à cette reprise c'est que
vous avez vous avez beaucoup de gens
quand même qui dans cette histoire ont
perdu beaucoup d'argent qu'ils n'ont pas
été aidés parce que ils n'étaient pas
éligibles à l'aide et qui ont eu des dd
il ya du business qui a été perdue donc
ce business là vous n'allez pas le
retrouver sous prétexte que on a on a
ouvert des cafés ou des dd restants et
puis je vous dis il ya les conditions
d'ouverture
comment ça va se faire là c'était ouvert
mais c'était ouvert à moitié sur les
terrasses seulement acsta donc vous avez
quand même beaucoup de questions et
c'est pas du tout évident que vous
reveniez au niveau d'avant comme ça en
claquant des doigts
vous avez eu de la casse vous avez eu de
la casse on a on en a parlé récemment
sur des taux de pauvreté qui ont explosé
ecsta donc ces gens là vont pas se
précipiter dans un récent donc voila et
or les toutes les prévisions tout les
tous les scénarios de sortie de la crise
sanitaire sortie d'ailleurs entre
guillemets un jeudi rien ne nous dit
qu'on n'aura pas un quatrième à une
quatrième vague ecsta donc pour
l'instant c'est c'est tout à fait c'est
tout à fait
ddd des plans sur la comète je dirais
donc on ré ouvre on va voir ce que ça
donnait mais la dernière fois qu'on a ré
ouvert ce n'était pas pour refermer
quelques mois plus tard donc et or c'est
bien ce qui s'est passé donc là
aujourd'hui on a de quoi être heureux on
a de quoi être content si vous vous
laissez c'est quand même un petit peu on
bloque tous ont fait couler tout le
monde et puis après il faudrait se
réjouir de de recommencer à moitié hier
c'est quand même un peu on nous vend du
rêve et malheureusement ça se transforme
vite en cauchemar donc voilà je dis
attention parce que les projections de
croissance et que c'est exceptionnel
on a eu je doute qu'elles soient
réalisées aussi facilement que ça
messieurs fantini vous êtes d'accord
avec cette analyse
oui je suis assez en phase en fait
effectivement une reprise comme ça est
très compliqué on manque cruellement de
visibilité sur la suite je pense que le
fait l'arrêt des perfusions de la
perfusion va être très délicate et
surtout il va y avoir un effet boomerang
sur l'année prochaine avec la reprise
des pg e avec la reprise de
l'endettement des des reports de charges
et tout ça et je pense qu'on va avoir un
deuxième coup fatal derrière et un autre
comme film en septembre octobre serait
dramatique pour la profession et
moralement terrible et ça alors terrible
pour les entrepreneurs pour les
restaurateurs hôteliers et autres mais
terrible aussi pour le recrutement à
l'attractivité dans ce métier et déjà
comme manque cruellement de compétences
là ça serait fatal alors justement vous
l'évoquez sur 650 mille salariés en
france que compte la filière
hôtellerie-restauration 100000 aurait
quitté le métier selon les estimations
des quatre syndicats des professionnels
de la restauration monsieur renseignez
vous l'avez dit c'est donc un phénomène
que vous constatez quelles solutions
s'offrent à vous à ce propos bella dans
l'immédiat très peu de solutions et je
le constate fortement puisque on
manquait déjà de compétences sur
certains secteurs du métier comme le
service en salle
on avait notre activité sur la cuisine
ou la pâtisserie parce qu'il ya des
émissions qui les valorise bien
mais sur la salle il y avait un gros
manque là aujourd'hui en a on a des
apprentis par exemple qui n'ont pas eu
de techniques pendant un an donc il a
aussi vont manquer de compétences
certains qui ont changé de métier et à
l'avenir il va falloir travailler sur le
long terme donc par exemple sur toulouse
on a travaillé fortement avec pôle
emploi
l'ensemble des missions locales et
autres et les institutions pour essayer
de de créer de l'attractivité de
recruter mais aussi de travailler sur le
fond du métier parce que je pense qu'il
va falloir revoir aussi tout à pédagogie
de formation pour qu'elle soit plus
attractive qu'elle soit actualisé avec
digital la rse ce cette période là aussi
modifier considérablement notre notre
métier et donc il va falloir se remettre
à niveau et ça c'est très long et j'ai
bien peur que là aussi on est une phase
délicate sur quelques années oui vous
avez peut-être une question à poser à
monsieur santini
oui le est-ce que
alors je sais pas du tout comment
comment les restaurateurs ont réagi
est-ce qu'ils ont eu beaucoup recours au
pge ou pas parce que le problème si vous
voulez c'est que c'est que c'est bien de
s'endetter mais quand il va falloir
commencer à rembourser
ça va être compliqué avec des chiffres
d'affaires dont on n'est absolument pas
sûr donc moelleux le principe même de
rambour de de remplacer de l'activité
par de la dette
me gêne quelque part un remplacer du
chiffre d'affaires par des prêts ça me
paraît toujours un peu incohérent mais
ce qui serait intéressant c'est de
savoir quelle est la proportion de
restaurateurs qui ont réellement eu
recourt pas au chômage partiel parce que
ça je pense que tout le monde il ya eu
recours
mais au pge alors écoutez j'ai pas de
chiffres exacts
en revanche ce qui est sûr c'est que je
pense que c'est une grosse partie en
tout cas sur le réseau que je connais de
restaurateurs et je suis en contact avec
beaucoup
une grosse partie après des ps ge je
suis complètement ne pas haïr ou sur le
problème du remboursement on a deux ans
de franchise mais l'année prochaine il
va falloir redémarrer les remboursements
et les faire en quatre ans donc qui à
mon avis va être très délicat puisque on
avait déjà des marges qui s'était
réduite par l'augmentation des matières
premières un coût de la vie qui qui est
délicat et qui s'est réduit aussi au vu
de la période
donc ça veut dire qu'on ne pourra pas
augmenter nos prix et donc pas augmenter
nos marges voulait réguler donc je pense
qu'il va y avoir un gros problème
un gros problème sur les remboursements
ça sera pas possible il faut absolument
rallongée de deux ans au moins au moins
les effets rance et deuxièmement je
pense qu'il ya des gens aussi qui ont
cumulé des dettes donc je pense que
c'est une grosse partie du métier parce
que les loyers ont continué à courir
même s'il ya eu des reports alors pour
les reports il ya des échéanciers qui
vont être maître donc c'est une charge
aussi décalé supplémentaires donc c'est
pour ça que je parlais d'un impact très
long et et je vous ai entendu dire qu'
il pouvait pas y avoir des aides
indéfiniment mais je pense que sur ce
secteur là il va falloir quand même
avoir une une vision de relance une
vision d'accompagnement un peu plus
longue
je pense aussi sur le secteur de paris
où il va pas y avoir de tourisme de sur
cet été et donc du coup une reprise plus
lente le secteur de l'événementiel et
des traiteurs qui va mettre du temps à
démarrer avec là aussi des jauges qui
vont qui vont bloquer idem sur le sport
donc tous ces métiers qu'ils soient un
peu lié
je pense quand même qu'il va falloir
réfléchir à accompagner sa est à prévoir
des passages délicats dans les
prochaines années je le répète mais
c'est important d'être ici c'est au
dessus
un monsieur font signer rapidement avant
de se quitter on l'a dit c'est une
réouverture inquiet par ces avec des
protocoles sanitaires des jauges de
remplissage vous comment est ce que vous
avez appréhendé ce protocole est ce
qu'il aurait mieux fallu selon vous
ouvrir par exemple le 9 juin
c'est une très belle question déjà déjà
on a en beaucoup d'endroits beaucoup
d'endroits 0 3 les équipes de reprendre
un rythme avec en plus des restrictions
qui sont délicates pour travailler
correctement
je pense en effet il faut pas faire les
difficiles on peut que se réjouir d'une
réouverture on a tous attendus on a tous
demandé
en revanche il est évident que
techniquement une ouverture au 9 juillet
la possibilité d'avoir 50 % à
l'intérieur combler les problèmes météo
une capacité terrasses pleines et et une
ouverture le soir un peu plus tardive
aurait permis d'avoir une meilleure
rentabilité aujourd'hui clairement c'est
l'équilibré être délicate où est ce qui
va résulter peut-être des complexités à
la reprise pour certains donc oui je
joue j'ai bien envie de vous dire que le
9 juin aurait été parfait et en même
temps je suis obligé de me réjouir de
cette ouverture
même si elle est délicate merci beaucoup
aux thomas fantini d'avoir été à parmi
nous dans cette émission je rappelle que
vous êtes pdg du groupe pergaud et
vice-président du medef hauts de garonne
merci beaucoup
avant d'accueillir attiré vers on va
marquer une courte pause et on se
retrouve dans un instant
bienvenue dans ces caches si vous nous
rejoignez au sommaire cette semaine la
réouverture des restaurants et des
commerces non essentiels et pour en
parler on va à présent accueillir at
tiri verront bonjour monsieur vous êtes
soit président de la fédération des
associations de commerçants et artisans
de paris bienvenue dans ces caches tu te
fais mais bonjour madame large
alors monsieur ayrault pour commencer et
quelle remontée est ce que vous vous
avez pour le moment des commerces qui
ont été qualifiés de non essentielle et
qui ont donc rouvert leurs portes
alors le premier mot c'est une grosse
inquiétude mais à côté de ça il ya quand
même la satisfaction de pouvoir ré
ouvrir alors je reviendrai sur
l'inquiétude après mais la satisfaction
elle vient aussi bien de des commerçants
mais également à des clients on s'est
aperçu que au bout de cette première
journée que les clients étaient
satisfaits de revenir dans nos commerces
de proximité de pouvoir être accueillis
par nos commerçants dirais presque à
bras ouverts
peut-être un peu au compte-gouttes
encore évidemment avec les jauges à
respecter mais il ya quand même c'est ce
besoin de contact dans les commerces
alors il ya que même à côté cédé
l'inquiétude elle vient du fait que si
on compare la première journée de
réouverture cette fois et pour la
première journée de réouverture du
premier continent le 11 mai 2020 sur
certains commerces
on a notamment sur les commerces qui
sont plutôt dans la décoration l'aliment
un chiffre d'affaires de 50 % en moins
mais justement l'objectif est de se dire
que la reprise sera aussi bonne que les
deux fois précédentes pour le moment
nous avons plutôt de bons indicateurs
c'est ce qu'a déclaré le président de la
société notamment des grands magasins
vous est-ce que quels sont les gens
discutent les indicateurs dont vous
disposez est ce que vous êtes dans le
même état d'esprit justement ça dépend
du type de commerce je pense parce que
sur certains commerces on se rend compte
que le les clients n'étaient pas encore
tous revenus notamment dans la
décoration et dans l'habillement
alors il faut peut être ajouté le fait
que
le
le temps ne s'y prêtait pas donc c'est
peut-être une des raisons
olivier peut-être avez-vous une question
pourrait céder roues oui enfin là je
pense que je vais rebondir un peu sur la
la la déclaration du président de la
société des grands magasins
il est évident de toute façon en sortie
de crise
c'est les gros qui vont tirer
probablement leur épingle du jeu
beaucoup plus facilement que les petits
donc là ça me paraît le la différence de
discours entre entre monsieur et le et
la déclaration de ce représentant des
grands magasins et pas étonnante
on sait très bien que ça va bénéficier
en premier lieu au gros chêne plutôt que
aux petits magasins indépendants donc
mais je pense que là aussi on va avoir
le même problème sur les magasins non
essentielles sur la restauration c'est
que très probablement il y en a beaucoup
qui ont utilisé des pge qui sont d'été
jusqu'au cou et quand le lait les aides
vont s'arrêter
il est assez probable ça fasse beaucoup
de dégâts donc je sais pas si vous avez
des statistiques sur le le le
l'endettement et le taux d'endettement
de ceux de ses magasins essentiel mais
je pense que ça va être très compliqué à
la reprise effectivement au niveau de
l'endettement les chiffres sont
compliquées avec hull et les
indépendants parce que vous avez
beaucoup d'indépendants qui n'ont pas
envie de parler de leurs problèmes je
suis dentier et c'est là où est toute la
difficulté c'est que quand vous avez mis
toutes vos économies dans votre commerce
il ya plusieurs années voire plusieurs
décennies
en fait c'est compliqué d'aller voir son
banquier ou voir même d'aller voir les
experts judiciaires qu'ils sont là aussi
pour faire du conseil gratuit
le problème c'est qu'en fait il ya aussi
une partie de communication qui a du mal
à passer et je pense que là c'est un
gros sujet il faut qu'on puisse
communiquer davantage je ne sais pas
comment mais sur les aides sur les
possibilités avant d'arriver à une
situation de deux de dépôt de bilan il
ya quand même pas mal de deux conditions
pour se sortir de l'ornière
il ya une chose qui est importante aussi
au niveau de la restauration avec les
les terrasses on le voit sur le sur
paris c'est que il ya en gros à peu près
40% des restaurants ils sont restés
fermés et qui rouvriront que le 9 juin
parce que installé quelques tables
devant déjà faut avoir la place pour
avoir une belle terrasse pour que ce
soit intéressant et les propulse la
fille retrouver financièrement mais il
ya également des personnes qui étaient
interrogés tout à leur disait
effectivement qui est le problème de
l'emploi alors c'est un gros si je vais
aussi je vais pas revenir dessus
puisqu'il il en a parlé pas mal
je suis en contact aussi avec les gens
de pôle emploi pour les dispatcher dans
les différents arrondissements mais le
problème c'est que l'équipe pour revenir
sur les cajas c'est très compliqué si
vous avez très peu de terrasse vous
pouvez pas faire grand chose et en fut
jeu avec les intempéries
c'est dramatique il ya aussi des
problèmes liés aux stocks au aux
touristes aussi qu'ils ne reviendront
peut-être pas en france tout à fait
justement je les jouais parler des
tourismes la grosse inquiétude vient de
là aussi parce qu'en fait si les
touristes ne reviennent pas comment on
voudrait puisque on sait déjà que les
américains fait c'est assez de santé et
reviendrait assez rapidement maintenant
il ya quand même une grosse clientèle
touristique asiatique qui est encore
avec un gros point d'interrogation ça on
ne maîtrise pas du tout et est-ce qu'ils
vont revenir et quand je vois des des
grands sites de
touristiques comme les châteaux les
musées ils sont vraiment très inquiet
donc c'est pareil on parlait de dz qui
allait diminuer progressivement
je pense que le e de la dégressivité des
bières des âmes va peut-être falloir
qu'elle soit décalée en fonction de deux
de cette arrivée ou pas de tourisme sur
sur la france justement mes yeux vairons
à ce propos sur la levée à des mesures
de soutien dont vous parliez il va
falloir être chirurgicale a prévenu un
économiste de la fcm à nos confrères de
la fp il levait trop rapide risquerait
un plongeon de certains secteurs avec un
emballement sur les faillites et des
risques sur l'emploi est ce que ce
calendrier
le calendrier de cette diminution
progressive des aides vous paraît
adaptée à la situation du terrain
alors à l'heure d'aujourd'hui c'est
difficile de se prononcer je pense que
dans les semaines dans la première
quinzaine de juin
on va voir comment comment se comportent
les les réservations
dans les hôtels etc
je pense qu'à partir de ce moment là on
aura peut-être un peu plus de lisibilité
c'est vrai que on navigue presque un
petit peu à vue et je pense qu'il faut
justement à partir de ce moment-là avoir
une possibilité de réactivité très forte
pour pouvoir dire voilà on avait prévu
de stopper les aident à telle date
vu les circonstances il va falloir qu'on
décale et je pense que ça il va falloir
être vigilant sur ce plan là parce qu'on
ne pourra pas on risque d'avoir des
beaucoup plus de dépôt de bilan que ce
qui risque de se passer est un autre
point qui est ainsi cessé les livraisons
au niveau des livraisons et je vois sur
sur paris on a énormément de 2 depuis ce
cyclable qui ont été développés avec on
appelle entre guillemets les couronnes à
piste on a demandé en souhaite avoir un
échange avec madame hidalgo pour revoir
point par point des secteurs qui sont
qui sont en train d'être carrément
sinistrés parce que même les livraisons
les livreurs ont du mal à rentrer pour
aller jusqu'à leur point de livraison
chez leurs clients
donc il ya une situation au niveau de la
mobilité qui est très importante aussi
et qu'il ne faut pas oublier parce que
on a nos clients aussi qu'ils viennent
de de banlieue de l'étranger voire même
de deux provinces ont besoin de venir
dans le commerce de proximité à paris
merci beaucoup tiré les vers en avoir
participé à cette émission je rappelle
que vous êtes président de la fédération
des associations de commerçants et
artisans de paris olivier merci à vous
c'est la fin de cette émission merci de
votre fidélité
on se retrouve la semaine prochaine pour
un nouveau numéro en attendant pour voir
ou revoir nos précédentes émissions ça
se passe sur rt france point tv
olivier on se quitte avec votre
traditionnel mot de la fin réjouissons
nous que les stations de ski et surtout
les remontées mécaniques est rouverte en
même temps que les bars et les
restaurants
nous allons pouvoir bientôt nous jeter
sur les pistes de ski re